So what are these systems and when should we be using them?
So the two systems that we have are the IK rig or
the full body IK or FBIK that we use within the control rig.
Now the IK rig is designed for a much more simple setup where you can create
different solvers and a full body solver, allowing you to make basic changes to
adjust your character's entire pose based on IK goals.
Using the FBIK within control rig just gives you a greater degree of flexibility.
It gives you access to a lot more settings and
you have a lot more control over things like squashing stretch,
making edits on a per bone basis,
like limiting the movement and rotation of some bones,
and even setting preferred angles so that the bones are definitely moving in the correct way.
Now these two different systems are using the same solvers under the hood,
so they're both built upon the same foundation.
The IK rig is useful for making basic changes to your character's pose,
and the full body IK within a control rig gives you essentially a lot more options
to tweak and customize the output of the final pose.
Now when is it appropriate to actually use a full body IK system?
So the systems are designed for editing your character's existing pose essentially,
so they're great for adjusting a pose that you have already,
dynamically, so at runtime in real time.
And they're great for things like reaching targets,
so pulling hands, heads, feet around to reach a given target location,
adjusting and aligning so that might be adjusting your spine or tails procedurally
if your character's running in there, they're sort of leaning left and right perhaps.
And they're great for ground alignment as well,
so whenever your character's walking on perhaps like an uneven terrain,
it's great for aligning each foot in a different way to the terrain
so that things look a bit more natural.
Something that it's not great for and not designed for
is generating new poses for your character from scratch.
So with the body there are just too many degrees of movement
then IK solver couldn't guarantee plausible posing
for anything like a human or an animal, anything fairly complex,
especially when you're moving effectors over great distances.
If that's something that you're hoping for,
then you'd be much better to build an actual control rig
and edit the pose of your character manually
because the full body IK system isn't designed to do that.